- What are you gonna do with the money?
Like, what do you need?
(light music)
All right Steve, we had a
good meeting, do you agree?
- Fabulous.
- Jets, Dolphins this weekend,
so it's usually a weird week for us.
- Well, you're on the right side now.
(laughing)
- All right, one piece of
advice for young entrepreneurs.
- One piece of advice,
believe in yourself.
- Period.
- Confidence.
- That's the most important thing.
- Love you, man. See ya later.
Great meeting with Steve this morning.
You know, anytime you're spending
obnoxious amounts of time
with billionaire football owners,
who also happen to be the
greatest human beings,
you're doing the right thing.
So good morning, good
start, gets me excited,
pumped up, looking forward to a vlog.
Love you guys,
and let's see how today goes.
See ya.
I think I just wanna play until I die.
You know, and that's why
when somebody likes it,
no matter what the fuck it is.
Once you love the game,
whatever that is, you win.
The problem is in entrepreneurship,
especially modern-day entrepreneurship,
we do not celebrate the game.
We're putting the riches on a pedestal.
You have to love the game.
I just don't know how you can
be a modern-day CPG business
and not have a disproportionate strategy
on Amazon, Walmart,
Saintsbury, Tesca, you know,
direct-to-consumer, Facebook,
Instagram conversion.
All this stuff is just so important.
How one can be a common
sense individual in 2018
and not start putting real effort towards
building those capabilities,
even if you're losing money
on your PNL in the short-term
to build up those capabilities,
blows my mind.
I am pumped that I'm doing an interview
and will be on the record,
I wanna be on the record
that the lack of effort, both
mentally and financially,
into direct-to-consumer
capabilities is the reason
the majority of the Fortune 500 CPG brands
will be in massive decline a
decade from this interview.
(light music)
It's the chase, it's the
process, it's the game,
and your energy consistently
is kinetic towards
this thing that I think is gonna
make you make the decisions
that won't let you get to the thing.
- Alright, you just want to look at this
next schedule with me real quick?
- Do I have another call? I
have a call two minutes ago.
Tyler's not on top of the
schedule the same way I am.
That needs to be discussed
more on the vlog.
I'm super-sharp, you know that's--
you know what must be disheartening?
You're so busy, busier than almost
every single person watching this.
The problem is, it's that
when I'm catching it,
you know you're not busier
than me, so there's that--
you've been suffocated out of the excuse
that would make so much
sense to everybody else.
The problem is, it's me
that's doing the catching.
- Yeah, no, I--
- Its heartbreaking out here.
This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
What's up dude? You look
cool with glasses, man.
That actually kind of caught me off-guard.
I genuinely think you look much better.
- Cool thanks.
- Do you think that too?
- Yes, I do.
- Do you?
- They help me to see.
- The fact that they help you to see,
and you're better looking and cooler--
- But a lot of people dig them.
- Dude, I didn't actually really,
for a hundredth of a second,
looking down, recognize you,
and I'm like, "Who's that
good-looking big man?"
(laughter)
- Yeah, I wore them to
a wedding on Saturday.
- Dude, I think you really, I
think your life has changed.
Yes, sir?
- Following up--
- Oh look at who's here,
talk about a handsome man.
- What's up boss? How you doing man?
- Getting back in shape,
doing the whole thing.
You can tell that the Gary
Dary V, getting back in shape.
- His Long Island accent that comes out
when he performs in the camera,
- We're from Long Island right?
- Is that a thing?
- It's not but I'm aware.
- Yeah, go ahead DeMayo.
- Where in Long Island are you from?
- I grew up in a town called Hewlett.
- Oh yeah, I'm from Malverne.
- Oh I didn't know that.
- By the way, 5-1-6 represent.
Following up with people on Instagram?
- I'll do it.
- Obviously not your VIP's.
- Oh, not the people in my inbox,
the people in the Instagram?
- Not the people that are like--
- Do it. Go through everyone
who hasn't replied, be like,
"Gary just asked me to check
in" and I'll come over the top.
- And then, also, a couple people have--
- How many have filled out?
- 55
- We have speakers, I'm excited.
- 55, once you-- I just
went back through our
list on social rank of everybody
that has 50-100K followers,
picked out about another 20 more people.
- I still think there's more people
that we didn't pick 100,000 and up,
so I'd like to find five minutes
to do that one more time
with you, and I'll be direct.
You know what I mean? 50
is getting into territory
where I'm not sure I want to do that.
- Okay, are you only interested in
hitting up people that follow you?
- Yes.
- The one person I was --
- Because when you cold
DM that way and their--
- But you have relationships
with people that don't follow.
- Yeah.
- Yes, I'm okay with that.
- Like that kid, the Benjamin Kicks.
Like, I don't think he follows you.
- Well I'm gonna punch
him in his fucking face.
Benji Kicks, I'm gonna
punch your fucking face
if you don't follow me.
Cool.
- Cool.
I'll get started.
A professional athlete is scary to me.
You live your whole life growing
up, you're gonna be this,
and by American standards for athletes,
somewhere in your 30's you're done.
Then you're lost.
That's why it's fun to see
the young athletes want to be
entrepreneurs because
they're all gonna have
a lot more to do.
(calming music)
I genuinely believe that
I sabotage my wealth
to string out my game.
I'm in it for the game.
Why don't I like the Yankees
and the Rangers anymore?
They won.
Now I only like the Knicks and the Jets.
It's the chase.
It's the process.
It's the game.
- G!
- My man!
- I been runnin' around man.
- Hustlin'.
- Yeah, brother it's crazy.
- Alright, what's up?
Is this it?
You need to send me jersey
to put in here, man.
- You don't have one of my jerseys?
- I do some --
You know?
You gotta have one?
- I got it.
- Send me one.
- The Jet one right?
- Yeah.
25.
Nah, not Arizona.
Get out.
I love you.
I'll see you soon man.
- I appreciate it, thank you.
- Yeah, appreciate it.
Kerry Rhodes.
The best.
(calming music)
And your energy consistently
is kinetic towards
this thing that I think
is gonna make you make
the decisions that won't
let you get to the thing.
My chase of the New York
Jets by eating the shit
18 hours a day is the lifestyle.
And we have 95 percent of the market
believing that the lifestyle is
you do something to get the fun stuff
and it's the 5 percent that understand the
process is the fun stuff
that get to buy the
95 percent of stuff.
You got it?
- [Caller] Yeah, that's
so trippy but so true.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- You got it brother.
That was just synthesized
to this whole game.
There's this thought that you
(puking sound)
and then, "Yay!".
Nuh uh!
The whole thing has to be
"Yay!", whether is results
in dollars that are here,
up here, or up here.
Unless you're in that
"Yay!" the whole way,
you're finished.
You're finished.
I think a lot of people
graduate from ice cream
to vacation home.
I think people are caught in the game.
I think people are confused, man.
Like to me the process of
making that cake is interesting.
The though of can I buy
the eggs for a good deal?
Can I create a flavor
of carrot cake mix with
mint chocolate chip that
no one's ever done before?
Can I be remembered for making great cake?
- [Bob] But you're also
not afraid to be wrong.
- That is damn right.
- [Bob] You're not afraid to be wrong.
- I'm not.
And I also will own it if I'm wrong.
I love being wrong
because I love the game.
And if I was wrong that
means the game is pure.
Of course, that's the best part.
And I didn't need it in my 20's
so I could buy a yacht to get girls.
I'm not that insecure.
An insecurity is what's hurting someone.
- [Bob] It depends what you want.
- Yes.
- [Bob] If all you want is
the yacht and the girls --
- You can do that.
- [Bob] You can do that.
- And you know what?
By the way, as a dude, sounds fun.
Jake wants it bad.
Jake.
- [Jake] Not really.
- Jake!
- [Jake] I wouldn't mind it.
- Okay.
(laughing)
Let's go to the next question.
That was amazing.
- Ben from Rhode Island.
- Ben.
(calming music)
What's up, vlog?
Super intense day.
A lot of meetings.
I don't know what Iris is
gonna get out of it but
heading to the Digital Uncorked.
It's a new concept that
Vayner Media has created.
A lot of people aren't
in a place financially
where they want to invest in the 4Ds,
10,000 dollar consulting
project so we created
a more intimate, fun,
obviously much shorter version
and using me instead of
the Vayner Media staff.
So we created called Digital Uncorked
$2,000 business dinner event and
I'm heading over there for the first one.
So I'm excited about our kind of new world
that we're involved in and
should be interesting to see how we can
deliver a lot of value
in this environment.
So, we'll see what's up.
(calming music)
You know I know a lot of you
came for the business stuff
but if we can achieve
anything for me because
I have so much love
for and is the platform
that my family, basically,
on the platform of wine
made it in America.
So, I have a lot of emotion for it.
If I can get you to try
new things, that would be
such a remarkable accomplishment.
Sanserre is especially interesting to me,
because I do think that
people that do like white wine
tend to get into Chardonnay and drink it
over and over and over.
What's cool about Sanserre,
and maybe you've seen this,
is it's not super heavy
but it's super crisp and complex.
So, it's interesting and
not boring like a lot of
average white wine that's
light and what have you.
But more importantly, it's an incredibly
flexible wine when it comes to food.
So, it's ability to do
with fish and salads
and light fare and by itself
is super interesting to me.
So, I hope you enjoy it.
It comes from a really good producer.
It's super clean.
If you're an oysters and
clams and shellfish fan
like I am, like this is a
hardcore pairing for that world.
So keep that in mind if
you want to nerd it up
or take a note.
And then finally,
I want you guys to do
something with all the wines
we have tonight, which is sniffy sniff it,
and here's what I mean by that.
The core thing that you can
do to really get into wine
is make sure you smell it.
And I don't mean this
smell that seems like kind
or cordial.
I mean getting your whole schnoz in there
and really smell it.
I've seen a lot of you taste wines?
Both the red and white already.
If you've tasted normal,
if you could now smell it
hardcore and then taste it again,
it'd be interesting to see
if you felt that it tasted
different than it did one minute ago.
I think for a lot of you,
you'll be really taken aback
on how extreme the flavor
profiles can be when you do that.
So, I want to allow you to do that.
So, in the theme of tonight,
I want to do a lot of
Q and A.
So, I kind of created my two frameworks.
I've walked around the first fourth.
I'll finish off in a little bit.
But, I'd like to open up the mic again,
I think that a lot of you
have a lot of context.
Some willing to go anywhere.
Answer anything from
any of your business
questions, hopes, aspirations.
I'm thrilled to talk.
New York Jets football.
Whatever you want to go
and talk about I'm here.
So, whose got a question?
One more time.
What's your goal?
In like black and white?
What do you think your goal is.
- Ah, man.
I thought about it a lot.
It's so easy to go back to revenue.
If that makes sense.
- Sure, of course.
Everybody thinks that
Revenue's a proxy.
So?
- I want to be able to hire
honestly at least 500 people.
- Why that number?
- Well, at least 500.
- You know what I'm most
worried about in our
couple interactions?
I feel like you're coming
up with arbitrary things.
Why not 700?
Why not at least 9,000?
Why is it a 500?
Can it be 150?
The fuck?
What does that all mean?
Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- Like, I don't think
that's the right way to
think about it.
From my perspective.
I could be wrong.
- Yep.
- But like I think
it has no actually grounding.
I wanted to buy a sports
franchise when I was little,
and the romantic part I learned English,
I get it that's cute, I like it.
But it was because I wanted
to make such a big goal
so that I could keep playing forever.
Getting to 500 employees
is going to be done
real quick if you're good enough.
Then what?
What you don't want to be is an athlete.
A professional athlete is scary to me.
You live your whole life.
Growing up you're gonna be this.
And by American standards for athletes,
somewhere in your 30's you're done.
And then you're lost.
That's why it's fun to
see the young athletes
want to be entrepreneurs because their all
gonna have a lot more to do.
It's an arbitrary number Rach.
Pay very close attention to my goal.
My goal is so ridiculous.
When you start trying to rush to 500,
you start over hiring
when you don't need it,
because it means like you're
getting closer to 500.
But having 113 or 157 means
no fucking real difference.
If you want the money,
that means you want to
buy something.
When people say to me, believe it or not
it's not about the money I'm like,
"Huh?".
It may be the ego of the
number, because at dinner
you want to tell your best friend it's now
13 instead of 8, maybe.
I get that.
I understand that.
I don't know, but like,
what are you going to do with the money?
Like what do you need?
The reason there's so few people
that actually get the things
because they're the ones
who are purebred, don't give a fuck
about the things.
Purebred.
Naturally.
I didn't manifest this.
I didn't force this.
I didn't read a book.
It came natural to me
to not want anything.
You need to really figure yourself out.
Because once you figure yourself out,
you're cruising.
You start rolling.
Once you figure yourself out
nobody has leverage on you,
because once you understand yourself,
you start putting yourself
in positions to not
let a lot of people have leverage on you.
And I don't want to let you do that.
- This is heavy.
- It's super heavy.
- Sorry, I'm pregnant.
- But, Rach it's good stuff.
- It really is.
- You have to go to
that next place because
you're just throwing things
at the wall and I get it.
The problem is that it's
going to feel real empty
when you get there.
And then when you love the game,
500 and 2047 just all goes away.
It all gets real slow.
You know?
I'm really glad you guys came out tonight.
(calming music)
Good event.
I don't like when D-Rock produces me so--
Well Iris could have asked.
Iris could have asked.
I don't like when D-Rock produces me.
I love
when Iris produces me.
- If you wanna do an outro to the evening
that would be awesome.
- Vlog, she's the best.
My outro is, it was a great fucking night.
The content in this event
was straight fucking fire.
And all three of you know it.
(calming music)